everybody who lives in the United States  should be fundamentally  uh wanting that an election whether you  agree with it or not needs to be  legitimized by each and every vote that  is cast that's just my personal opinion  and I'm sorry and so I don't get into  the weeds of whether there was enough  votes that were illegitimate to have  changed the outcome but I do know and by  the way it's indisputable that there was  at least one vote that was cast that was  illegitimate meaning that there were  votes that were cast that happened to be  people that were dead that to me  illegitimizes the entire process that's  offensive to me personally and that's  offensive to me as being an American